los primeros pasajeros procedentes de
China se sometieron el domingo a las
pruebas covid en el aeropuerto George de
gol de París Francia se ha convertido en
el último país en exigir a los pasajeros
que salen de China que den negativo en
la prueba antes de subir al avión un
requisito que también se complementa con
pruebas aleatorias a las llegadas según
explicó el ministro de sanidad françois
esta prueba la llegada no es un control
que impide a los ciudadanos entrar en
nuestro territorio sino más bien un
control científico que nos permitirá
seguir de manera extremadamente precisa
las diferentes variantes esencialmente
la variante omicron que se encuentra
actualmente en China
los casos de covid se han disparado en
China desde que el gobierno revocó
abruptamente su política de cero covid a
principios de diciembre varios países
han impuesto medidas a Los viajeros
procedentes de gente asiático por temor
a que Beijing no facilite datos
adecuados Francia Espera que pronto haya
una respuesta europea coordinada a los
viajes desde china
vamos a tener un debate esta semana para
armonizar este modelo de gestión a nivel
europeo como saben los españoles y los
italianos ya han tomado estas medidas
también lo han hecho los estadounidenses
pero en cualquier caso Francia va a
impulsar este método para que se adopten
todos los países de la Unión Europea
el requisito es un inconveniente más
para Los viajeros procedentes de China
donde las pruebas obligatorias son una
realidad cotidiana desde hace más de un
año el país sigue exigiendo que las
personas que entran pasen la cuarentena
su llegada una medida que el gobierno
suprimirá a partir del 8 de enero cuando
reabra sus fronteras por primera vez en
tres años